Vladimir Putin está obsesionado con los libros
de historia…
Especialmente, y seguro que esto no sorprende
a nadie, con todos aquellos que tratan sobre
el pasado imperial de la madre patria Rusia.
Y, ojo, que no se trata solo de la lectura.
En el Kremlin - y en general a lo largo y
ancho de toda Rusia - Putin ha colocado estatuas
de históricos monarcas como Pedro el Grande
y Catalina la Grande.
Y esto, queridos amigos, amigas, nos da muchas
pistas sobre lo que está ocurriendo.
¿Por qué?
Pues porque precisamente estos dos monarcas
rusos conquistaron para Rusia buena parte
de lo que hoy conocemos como Ucrania.
Claro que Putin va mucho más allá.
Para él Ucrania es indiscutiblemente parte
de Rusia y, por tanto, su historia y sus gentes
también lo son.
Por ejemplo, en 2016, justo a las puertas
del Kremlin Putin mandó levantar una estatua
de Vladimir el Grande, príncipe del Principado
de Kiev en el siglo X.
Por supuesto para Putin, el príncipe Vladimir
fue un ruso de pura cepa.
De hecho, ni más ni menos el ruso que abrazó
el cristianismo y completó el espíritu nacional
de lo que hoy es la madre Rusia.
Así que no tiene ningún sentido hablar de
la historia de Ucrania.
De hecho, el propio Putin en el año 2008
le dijo al presidente norteamericao George
Bush que Ucrania no es un país real.
Y en la víspera de la cruel invasión que
desató la terrible guerra que hoy estamos
presenciando en territorio ucraniano, acusó
al mismísimo Vladimir Lenin de traicionar
y destruir el imperio ruso al crear una nueva
república: la república socialista soviética
de Ucrania.
Y otras 13 repúblicas además de Rusia.
Y, ¿sabéis qué?
Todo apunta a que él mismo se ve como el
líder, el responsable de volver a construir
el imperio ruso.
Exactamente en esta misma línea el 9 de junio
de 2022, en una reunión con jóvenes empresarios,
Putin dijo dos cosas:
Primero que Ucrania no es ni será nunca un
país soberano.
Incluso habló de “colonia”
Y segundo, se comparó con Pedró el Grande,
cuando este libró la “Gran Guerra del Norte”
contra Suecia durante 21 largos años para
devolverle a Rusia su grandeza.
Ahora bien, estamos en VisualPolitik, y esto
no es ninguna clase de historia.
Por supuesto, la historia puede jugar un papel
muy importante, pero el pasado nunca puede
ser un límite al presente o al futuro.
Más allá de si Ucrania fue o no parte de
Rusia o si sus habitantes hablan o no ruso,
hoy es un país independiente y soberano.
Exactamente igual que Estados Unidos, Australia,
Canadá o Irlanda lo son del Reino Unido.
Su pasado como parte del Imperio britanico
y el hecho de que hablen inglés no le da
a Londres ningún derecho histórico.
Pero al líder ruso todo esto le da exactamente
igual.
En 2021 publicó un tratado de unas 5.000
palabras sobre “la unidad histórica de
rusos y ucranianos”.
Un tratado en el que Putin defiende que rusos,
bielorrusos y ucranianos forman un mismo pueblo
bajo que ahora Moscú tiene que volver a integrar
por las buenas…
O por las malas.
Y eso exactamente lo que intentó el día
24 de febrero cuándo lanzó lo que pensaba
sería una rápida, exitosa y gloriosa invasión
de Ucrania.
Claro que, como todos sabemos, lo que ocurrió
entonces fue totalmente diferente.
Putin ahora mismo ya no tiene la oportunidad
de ser el constructor del nuevo imperio ruso,
sino más bien el responsable de hundir a
la patria.
Su campaña en Ucrania ha destrozado al ejército
ruso que ahora va de derrota en derrota e
incluso ha perdido el buque insignia de la
armada del Mar Negro.
Para colmo, ahora está en camino de hundir
también la economía nacional.
Vladimir Putin se está convirtiendo en el
peor enemigo de la ambición imperial rusa.
El desastre está siendo tan grande que de
unos 190 mil efectivos que componían la fuerza
de invasión inicial, las bajas entre muertos
y heridos se calculan en unas 100 mil.
("El ejército ruso ha tenido un rendimiento
peor de lo que jamás hubiera imaginado.
Es demasiado pronto para planear un desfile
de la victoria aquí, pero creo que los ucranianos
están a punto de lograr un impulso irreversible
mientras nosotros, Occidente,sigamos estando
con ellos" Ben Hodges, ex general al mando
de los ejércitos de Estados Unidos en Europa)
Un buen ejemplo de lo está siendo la campaña
lo tenemos en la estratégica ciudad de Kupyansk
a orillas del río Oskil.
Una importante encrucijada de ferrocarriles
y carreteras.
Pues bien, durante 195 días esta ciudad no
solo vivió bajo la ocupación rusa sino que
se convirtió en uno de los centros más importantes
de la administración militar rusa.
Por aquí pasaban y se organizaban los suministros
críticos a las líneas del frente.
Era una de los fortines clave en la maquinaria
de guerra de Moscú.
Y sin embargo pese a ello el 10 de septiembre
de 2022, la nonagésima segunda Brigada Mecanizada
de Ucrania capturó esta ciudad e hizo volver
a ondear las banderas azules y amarillas.
Increíble pero cierto.
¿Otro ejemplo?
Pues ahí tenemos el caso de Kherson.
La ciudad se llenó de carteles que decían
que la ciudad sería rusa para siempre.
Incluso, como luego veremos, Rusia se la anexionó
junto a la mayor parte del Oblast.
Sin embargo, pese a la anexión, a los carteles
y a todo lo anunciado, 8 meses después de
ocuparla los rusos tuvieron que retirarse
y la ciudad ha vuelto a ser ucraniana.
Pero cómo os decía lo peor para Rusia puede
estar por llegar: las sanciones internacionales
están dañando la economía rusa, el tope
al precio del petróleo puede terminar por
hundir los ingresos del gobierno, muchos jóvenes
han fallecido en la guerra o están escapando
de Rusia y muchos países están ya suspendiendo
grandes contratos con la industria rusa.
Por ejemplo, Indonesia y Filipinas han anulado
grandes contratos militares con la industria
rusa.
En el caso de Indonesia hablamos de un contrato
multimillonario para la compra de cazas Sukhoi-35.
Aviones que hoy serán reemplazados por equipos
franceses y norteamericanos.
(Indonesia compra aviones de combate estadounidenses
y franceses por valor de 22.000 millones de
dólares: el Su-35 ruso perdió.
El cambio de rumbo de Indonesia, que ha pasado
de un acuerdo con Rusia a nuevos acuerdos
de compra con Estados Unidos y Francia, pone
de manifiesto la potencia de las sanciones
estadounidenses.
The Diplomat)
Y ahí no termina todo.
Además, la posición internacional es cada
vez más delicada.
Sin ir más lejos, una Comisión de Investigación
del Consejo de Derechos Humanos de Naciones
Unidas ha publicado un durísimo informe que
acusa a la Federación Rusa de cometer múltiples
crímenes de guerra durante la inversión.
Hablamos de ejecuciones, torturas, violaciones
y, por supuesto, el constante bombardeo de
zonas e infraestructuras civiles.
Es decir, el relato ruso hace aguas por todas
partes.
Y para colmo el frente cada día está peor.
Si los ucranianos siguen empujando y la ayuda
occidental continúa llegando Rusia se arriesga
a sufrir una catastrófica derrota.
Lo que podría suponer el propio final de
Putin.
Y ante esa situación hay una pregunta que
se ha propagado a los cuatro vientos:
¿Estará Rusia dispuesta a escalar el conflicto
y llegado el caso utilizar armas nucleares?
¿Podría esto cambiar el rumbo de la guerra?
¿Puede el Kremlin lograr un acuerdo de paz
que le permita lavar la cara?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
(LA ÚLTIMA BALA)
El día 30 de septiembre de 2022, el presidente
ruso firmó la incorporación a la Federación
Rusa de los Oblast ucranianos de Lugansk,
Donetsk, Zaporizhia y Kherson.
Fue, al menos formalmente, la mayor toma forzosa
de territorio en toda Europa desde la Segunda
Guerra Mundial.
Podríamos decir que el objetivo de Putin
con esta anexión era demostrarle al pueblo
ruso que la guerra estaba teniendo algún
sentido.
Que lejos de producirse una derrota, Rusia
estaba ganando territorio.
El problema es que ni siquiera esto está
ocurriendo exactamente así.
Es cierto que Rusia no ha delimitado el territorio
que se ha anexionado - lo cuál parece una
broma de mal gusto - pero aún así la ofensiva
ucraniana en Kherson y la expulsión de las
tropas rusas al este del río Dnieper ha resultado
humillante.
Si la propaganda rusa le vendió al mundo
y también a los propios rusos que Kherson
sería para siempre una ciudad rusa, hoy ya
no lo es.
Y, ojo, porque tras la anexión y desde el
punto de vista ruso las ofensivas ucranianas
se están dirigiendo ya contra el propio territorio
de Rusia…
¿Y qué significa esto?
Pues teóricamente y con las propias reglas
del Kremlin ahora Moscú está perdiendo la
guerra en casa.
Por tanto ya no se puede hablar de una operación
especial.
Y, el problema, queridos amigos, amigas, es
que Vladimir Putin es como un jugador adicto
al Poker que siempre, siempre, sube su apuesta.
Esa ha sido al menos la experiencia hasta
ahora.
Por ahora está perdiendo todas las partidas.
Lo que ha hecho saltar muchas alarmas.
(2 de noviembre de 2022: “Kiev dice que
está preparando 425 refugios en caso de un
ataque nuclear ruso.
NY Times)
Acorralado, humillado, derrotado…
Cambiar el curso de la guerra parece prácticamente
imposible, pero ¿Podría el régimen de Putin
intentar un ataque nuclear que obligue a Occidente
y a la propia Ucrania negociar un alto el
fuego?
¿Podría el Kremlin llevar al extremo nuclear
su presión para que la guerra termine ya
y Putin pueda venderle a los rusos las conquistas
logradas?
Y ojo, que no hablamos de ninguna hipótesis
racional.
Rusia ha destrozado su ejército en Ucrania
pero sigue teniendo una fortaleza: su arsenal
nuclear.
Y no hablamos ya de las grandes bombas nucleares
capaces de arrasar ciudades y regiones al
completo.
Sino de su arsenal de cerca de 2.000 armas
nucleares tácticas de entre 1 y 10 kilotones.
Armas, por lo general, mucho más pequeñas
que nunca se han empleado en combate pero
que fueron diseñadas no para arrasar una
ciudad sino para para enfrentarse a un ejército
convencional en el campo de batalla.
Un arsenal que Putin y los altos gerifaltes
del Kremlin podrían plantearse utilizar en
un momento de desesperación como golpe de
fuerza.
("Tenemos nuestro propio potencial militar.
Si alguien piensa que no lo usaremos si hay
una amenaza grave, entonces se equivoca" Dmitry
Novikov, vicepresidente del comité de relaciones
exteriores de la Duma)
("Imaginemos que Rusia se ve obligada a usar
sus armas más formidables contra el régimen
ucraniano, que ha cometido un acto de agresión
a gran escala que está poniendo en peligro
la existencia misma de nuestro estado.
Creo que la OTAN no interferirá directamente
en el conflicto ni siquiera en ese escenario"
Dmitry Medvedev, diputado
El propio Putin amenazó por primera vez con
usar armas nucleares justo al comienzo de
la invasión.
Fijaos.
(“Rusia sigue siendo uno de los estados
nucleares más poderosos.
Además, tiene cierta ventaja en varias armas
de vanguardia.
En este contexto, no debería haber ninguna
duda para nadie de que cualquier agresor potencial
se enfrentará a la derrota y a consecuencias
ominosas si ataca directamente a nuestro país.
Vladimir Putin)
Y con la llegada del otoño los grandes reveses
en el campo de batalla.
Las amenazas del Kremlin se multiplicaron.
Y, ojo, porque esto es lo que explica noticias
como esta:
(10 de noviembre de 2022: El general de mayor
rango de Estados Unidos insta a la diplomacia
en Ucrania mientras los asesores de Biden
se resisten El general Mark A. Milley, jefe
del Estado Mayor Conjunto, ha defendido que
los ucranianos deben intentar consolidar sus
logros en la mesa de negociaciones.)
(23 de noviembre de 2022: Guerra en Ucrania:
Emmanuel Macron anuncia que tendrá "contacto
directo" con Vladimir Putin "en los próximos
días''.
Atlántico)
os importante avances ucranianos que han puesto
a Rusia contra las cuerdas, han hecho que
por primera vez se multipliquen las presiones
para que se negocie un alto el fuego y el
conflicto no siga escalando.
Y es que la pregunta es, si Rusia está perdiendo
la guerra, ¿Por qué demonios no echar mano
de su arsenal nuclear?
Pues bien, queridos amigos, amigas, existen
6 buenas razones por las que es poco probable
que Rusia utilice su arsenal nuclear.
O mejor dicho 6 buenos motivos por las que
recurrir a las armas nucleares sería un tremendo
error para Rusia.
Atentos.
T2(EL DISPARATE NUCLEAR)
Utilizar un arma nuclear para evitar la derrota
en Ucrania puede tener cierto sentido…
Hasta que esta cuestión se analiza con tranquilidad.
Lo cierto es que existen buenas razones para
pensar que Moscú no utilizará armas nucleares
en Ucrania.
En concreto podemos destacar 6 grandes motivos.
Primero existen mejores alternativas militares.
Me explico.
En caso de recurrir al uso de armas nu✓cleares
para dar un golpe en la mesa, la opción lógica
sería el uso de armas nucleares tácticas
contra el ejército ucraniano.
Sin embargo, frente a lo que podríamos pensar,
el uso de estas armas supondría escalar el
conflicto sin conseguir probablemente ninguna
ventaja militar.
(Las armas nucleares tácticas equipan por
lo general ojivas pequeñas que fueron ideadas
para atacar fuerzas de combate numerosas y
concentradas.
Pero el ejército ucraniano no opera con una
gran concentración de fuerzas y además está
en consw tante movimiento con lo cual los
daños serían limitados.
De hecho, para las armas por debajo de los
10 kilotones, sus efectos son superados por
la artillería de alta precisión y las armas
termobáricas que ya se han utilizado en el
frente.)
De esta forma, derrotar la capacidad militar
de Ucrania requeriría del uso de docenas
y docenas de armas nucleares tácticas.
Por ejemplo, en los planes del ejército de
Estados Unidos durante la guerra fría se
contemplaba emplear 136 bombas nucleares tácticas
para limpiar un frente de 100 km.
El frente actual entre Ucrania y Rusia se
extiende a lo largo de más de 600 kilómetros.
C5("Sus armas nucleares son más útiles para
ellos cuando no las usan.
Simplemente no hay ninguna ventaja en el campo
de batalla por usar un arma nuclear".
General retirado Ben Hodges, ex comandante
general del ejército de Estados Unidos en
Europa,)
Por supuesto estas armas podrían ser útiles
para atacar centrales eléctricas e infraestructuras…
Pero su empleo tendría muchas más consecuencias
sin marcar ninguna diferencia.
Y esto nos lleva directamente al segundo motivo:
El uso de armas nucleares no supondría el
final del problema para Rusia, sino más bien
todo lo contrario.
Sería el fin de la solución.
El uso de armas nucleares de cualquier calibre
conllevaría una rotunda condena internacional.
Una condena mucho mayor que la causada por
la propia guerra.
La presión contra Rusia sería tan grande
que las sanciones se generalizarían por todo
el mundo, incluyendo sanciones secundarias
que harían que países relativamente amistosos
como la India o Emiratos Árabes dejarán
de serlo.
La presión occidental alcanzaría niveles
inimaginables y Rusia se convertiría en un
país radiactivo, nunca mejor dicho.
Algo así como una nueva Corea del Norte,
lo que por supuesto sería fatal para los
ciudadanos rusos y para los propios oligarcas
y gerifaltes del país que ya no encontrarían
refugio.
(Incluso países como China ya han dejado
claro que eso es una línea roja.
¿Por qué?
Pues porque si Rusia usa armas nucleares la
no proliferación se iría hacer puñetas.
Muchos países del sudeste asiático se lanzarían
de lleno a desarrollar sus propias armas nucleares
como seguro de vida.
Y todo ello para que Rusia no consiga una
clara ventaja militar.)
Pero no sólo hablamos de una reacción política
o económicaee.
Sino también quizás de una militar.
Washington ha sido muy claro: el uso de armas
nucleares conllevaría una respuesta contundente
por parte de occidente.
Esto es algo que tanto el Secretario de Defensa,
Lloyd Austin, como el Jefe del Estado Mayor
conjunto, el general Mark Milley, o el Asesor
de Seguridad Nacional Jake Sullivan se han
encargado de trasladar a los altos gerifaltes
rusos.
C6("Hemos comunicado directamente, en privado,
a niveles muy altos, al Kremlin que cualquier
uso de armas nucleares tendría consecuencias
catastróficas para Rusia, que Estados Unidos
y nuestros aliados responderán con decisión.
Y hemos sido claros y específicos sobre lo
que eso implicaría" Jake Sullivan, Asesor
de Seguridad Nacional de la Casa Blanca.)
No sabemos exactamente a qué tipo de respuesta
se refiere Sullivan, pero lo que se ha filtrado
es que en caso de ataque nuclear la OTAN,
respondería con un ataque convencional a
gran escala para destruir las fuerzas rusas
en Ucrania y garantizar la soberanía de este
país.
Otra posi✓ble respuesta podría ser entregarle
a Ucrania equipos mucho más avanzados y letales.
Por ejemplo equipos de ataque a larga distancia
o, incluso, toda una fuerza aérea.
Y visto lo visto está claro que de producirse
está respuesta el resultado podría ser la
aniquilación de las fuerzas rusas en Ucrania.
C7("Hasta donde sabemos, Putin está amenazando
con usar armas nucleares tácticas en suelo
ucraniano, no para atacar a la OTAN, lo que
significa que la OTAN debe responder de una
manera convencional.
Pero la respuesta debería ser devastadora.
Y supongo que este es el mensaje claro que
la alianza de la OTAN está enviando a Rusia
en este momento".
Zbigniew Rau, Ministro de Asuntos Exteriores
de Polonia)
Todos hemos visto lo que ha ocurrido con el
ejército convencional.
A priori Rusia debería haber derrotado rápidamente
Ucrania pero la corrupción, la falta de equipos,
las carencias de entrenamiento y el pobre
mantenimiento han hecho que la guerra sea
una pesadilla.
Pues bien, seamos claros, es poco probable
que las armas nucleares de Rusia estén en
mucho mejor estado que sus fuerzas convencionales.
Y, ¿os imagináis lo que supondría un error
o un fallo en el uso de estas armas?
Podría ser el golpe de gracia para el Kremlin.
E, incluso, podría terminar dañando a su
propio ejército.
Y, ojo, que esto no es una probabilidad menor.
Rusia es un país en el que encontramos noticias
como esta:
N5(8 de diciembre del 2020: Ladrones roban
el equipo de radio del avión ruso del "día
del juicio final.
Unos ladrones han robado equipos electrónicos
de un avión militar ruso conocido como "avión
del juicio final" por su papel en el arsenal
nuclear del país, informan los medios locales.
BBC)
Y por supuesto, existe el riesgo de que la
escalada fuera exponencial.
Este es el quinto motivo.
Desde la guerra fría se tuvo claro que las
armas nucleares eran artefactos de disuasión
no de agresión.
El empleo de armas nucleares podría terminar
provocando daños inimaginables para todos.
Ese fue el equilibrio de la destrucción mutua
asegurada en el que se han formado los propios
gerifaltes rusos.
Todos son conscientes de las consecuencias
y todos tienen familias y amigos.
De hecho eso hace que el empleo de armas nucleares
tampoco sea algo popular en casa.
Por ejemplo, Igor Ivánovich Strelkov, un
líder paramilitar que fue clave en la toma
de Crimea y en la guerra del Donbass ha dejado
claro que el uso de armas nucleares sería
un error, e incluso, un crimen.
Todos estos motivos explican porque nunca
se han vuelto a utilizar armas nucleares:
no ocurrió ni en la guerra de Corea, ni en
la guerra de Vietnam, ni en Afganistán ni
tampoco en la propia guerra de Ucrania a pesar
de que Rusia ha perdido ya decenas de miles
de hombres.
Las consecuencias podrían ser tan graves
que incluso aunque Putin perdiera la cabeza
el incentivo a frenarle sería muy grande.
Evidentemente si algo nos enseña la historia
es que la realidad puede terminar superando
cualquier escenario probable.
Pero, amigos, amigas, más allá del mundo
de los dementes, es poco probable que Rusia
eche mano de su arsenal nuclear.
Sea como sea el problema es que Ucrania no
se puede permitir una salida en falso.
Un acuerdo de paz sin grandes cesiones por
parte de Rusia podría condenar de forma permanente
a este país.
Y eso es algo que los ucranianos difícilmente
aceptarán.
Pero llegados hasta aquí turno para ti:
¿Creés que la Rusia de Putin se atreverá
a usar armas nucleares?
¿Creés que el fin de la guerra puede estar
próximo?
Déjanos tus impresiones en los comentarios
y ahora si este vídeo os ha resultado interesante
no olvides darle a like y suscribiros a VisualPolitik.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.